so one of the things that really
impressed me about the movie was that
how fast how well-cut it was how fast
moving it was but it never felt like it
was on fast forward it felt like it was
just really well cut to me and it really
pulled me in can you talk about finding
the film in the editing room you know
and finding that pace that you wanted to
deliver the story I thought it's quite
early on people would say what's this
hypnotic and I would just say it's it's
Hitchcock on steroids I meant what I
meant really was the pace I thought you
know Hitchcock films were older films
and I thought I would love to bring like
a Relentless Pace to a thriller I think
that would be really fun but then also
because the covid shutdowns we had so
little time to shoot this thing it was
shot like Mariachi almost like I
couldn't make some of those shots any
longer we had to go really tight so I
had to be very economical and as I was
editing it together I just thought I
just want to make this thing pull you
along to where you don't even realize
how fast is moving and then my son wrote
a score he was not a thriller type score
necessarily like a Hitchcock Thriller he
made it much more propulsive it's very
propulsive so I think the mix of the
music and the edits makes it feel like
it's grabbing you like this and and
pulling you through I think that it was
that combination the sound and and the
picture edits
um I I didn't really have to find
anything I was just cutting what we shot
because that's I had to shoot almost
like one to one did you I don't know if
you want to share but actually how long
did you have to shoot the movie
originally it was going to be 55 days
which is you know pretty luxurious it's
it's not just
bad for me the way I shoot that's a lot
of time that's good that's about a way
to do you know on a Sin City type movie
but because we had to shut down three
times every time we got shut down we'd
have to find money in the budget
somewhere and the easiest way to cut
budget is to cut days so I went from 55
day then the second time it cut down to
40 days and the second time we shot down
to 34 days but it wasn't like a 12 to 14
hour day they were French hour 10 hour
days which when you change locations
several times a day like we had to
that's more like a six to eight hour day
so that's like a 24 Day schedule so I
had to spin it in a good way I thought
Ben's going to hate this but I thought
wait a minute he's from the 90s too so I
said hey Ben it's going to be like the
Roaring 90s man remember when we started
we were shooting from the hip Indie
style and he went yeah I didn't think
anyone shot like that anymore I stand
around a lot on sets I said let's let's
do it that way so he was into it and we
had such a blast I think it brought an
energy to it that reminded me of oh I
got the Hitchcock experience he was so
tired of the bloated budgets and the
long schedules that he said man this TV
thing is the way to go I'm gonna take my
TV crew we're gonna shoot psycho in
black and white and shoot fast so this
was kind of like our psycho we had to
just shoot it very quick but I think
that's why I feel so
fast because we had to shoot it fast and
we didn't have time to shoot extra
that would have just slowed the edit
down so we kind of had to just go with
the essentials and cut it and get it
down to the to the it's like a 90 minute
movie right it's like 94 minutes yeah
dude well first of all let me say on
camera how much I enjoyed this
um listen I'm a fan of your work but I
really enjoyed this movie and I enjoyed
the world that you created so I have to
ask you there's obviously people that
have this power did you consider when
you were writing well if there if people
have this power then there's other
people that must have another Power yeah
I mean I loved the Oh I thought it could
easily be a TV series it could be like a
series of movies I thought the idea was
really big and one of my
Secrets I've you know kind of not
realizing it early on was if you have a
small or medium-sized budget don't come
up with a small idea for it or a
medium-sized idea always come up with a
really big idea because then if you you
can have a slide roll to figure out what
your budget is if you don't get a big
budget it still works so if the idea is
really big and you ask questions like
that by the end of it
that's a big idea you know or tints are
spies all you have to do is put
sunglasses on them and have some sound
effects and and you've already fulfilled
the vision because the idea is just so
big you can make them for a small to
medium budget so that's why I get more
creative freedom when I can make of
those smaller budgets but I always try
to marry it with a big idea and what I
loved about the idea of this why I stuck
with it so long is that it's what we do
as storytellers and as filmmakers we
create a hypnotic construct that
hopefully is strong enough that the
audience believes what they're seeing
even though they know it's actors and
lines enough to cry or laugh or cheer or
say hey I really like this and and get
their friends to go see it too and to
pull back the layers like that within
the movie is really fun to intercut and
because of the budget we've started
running out of
sometimes all we had was pipes and a
sign and a golf cart and it's like that
only makes the hypnotic
so it made them
made them have so much taken away from
us I had to rely on my old Mariachi
tricks and uh and it really was it was
really fun I think people will sense the
fun that we had making it I don't want
to do a spoiler but you haven't after
the credit scene and I I don't want to
well that's right it's talking about it
people will see it I'm gonna try and
tweet out go see them the mid credit
sequence anyway yeah well I'm just
curious did you always know that was
going to be there and was it almost was
it ever something else that's the ending
was pretty much the same for the past
seven years I came up with that ending
when I realized
you know it's all about family I kind of
want one more twist and and I didn't
have that twist originally
um you know 20 years ago but I just
thought the other twist is the one
you're talking about that's an extra one
I always forget about that was always
just part of the sequence it didn't cut
to credits it was just uh it was just
happened right away
and I just thought let me move it so
that it doesn't take away from the from
the ending
but it's there I still want it there
hope it's not too far down the mid
credits because it's not
it's not a market I don't know if
everyone's going to stick around like
they do to a Marvel movie but hopefully
people see it because people flipped out
at South by Southwest when that ending
came up and you know some people will
and some people won't but the people who
did they really really love that extra
ending at the end so I wasn't sure I
mean sometimes you don't know with a
thriller and you know people you know
um
you know what people are gonna always
have different reactions right so it's
like which is the right one I usually
tend to go with the thing that I like
most because then it's true to at least
somebody and I think other people will
respond to that and those who don't you
don't you know you're never gonna win
everybody over but
um
I I I wanted it in there somewhere
because I thought it was cool and it was
such a two dollar trick I mean it's such
a genetic trick it's an edit trick that
just if I did it with my iPhone to show
the actors what we were doing and they
couldn't believe what they were seeing
they thought they were seeing things
like oh this is like the Hitchcock
method no visual effects needed it's
just a it's just a sleight of hand trick
that's what most of the movie is my
favorite sequences are are just two
dollar edits and the editing was so fun
to do I had such a blast editing edited
like in three weeks that's how much fun
I was having I was just like boom boom I
wanted to see how each scene uh ended
and um and so many just fun tricks that
you can do with no no dollars no man
like I said I really enjoyed it and uh I
have like a minute or two left I want to
hit you up really fast with a few
questions as a fan of your work
um I know the writer's strike is going
on right now but do you think you're
going to be filming anything this year
could be I mean I have something that
we're hoping goes at the end of the year
but I needed to turn in another draft so
I don't know how long that's gonna take
why is that do you want to come visit
this hedge come visit us at uh no I just
wanted I want to see more movies from
you oh okay well that worked pretty fast
so as soon as I get you we'll have
something out pretty quick we have
another Spike coming out that's really
great coming out this year from Netflix
that's that's my next question I'm
obviously looking forward to the new Spy
Kids on Netflix uh do you have a release
date when are you gonna release footage
never I can't I don't know if I can see
the release date but it's it's coming
it's this year I don't know if we
haven't announced it yet but it's coming
this year do you know if fans will get
it I just finished scoring it so you
know we still waiting for visual effects
it won't be done it won't be done to
August it won't be any earlier than
August so it's like November December
something like that
yeah I understand as I tried to ask you
at the beginning
wait what not earlier but it won't be
August yeah no no totally because they
need time to put it all together but as
you know I am a big fan of Elita I I saw
John say something about Elita I have to
ask you is there movement on more Elite
I mean movement other than us talking
about it you know I I just wasn't sure
it was ever going to happen because even
when the first movie came out
um
Disney had just bought Fox so even like
our marketing people everybody were gone
by the time that movie came out but um
and then there wasn't any fox movies
being made for years because you know
Disney was still busy making their own
Disney stuff but now they've been I've
seen some fox movies come out yeah
there's been some fox movies so
that gave me hope and then when John
mentioned that and then Jim and I had
been talking that we always wanted to do
an Elita sequel he outlined very you
know thoroughly into the third film so
there's already material there so uh
yeah we're hoping you know
that that that'll happen so yeah that
did but then nothing more definitive
than that yeah look I'm hoping whatever
it takes Disney plus theaters whatever
it takes I would love for you guys to do
more yeah we'd love to we really loved
collaborating and and we want to do we
definitely want to do another one I
gotta rap with you I'm just gonna say
congrats on this film and I really do
hope it's a big hit for you and as
always if there's ever anything I can do
on collider for you please let me know
appreciate it thank you so much man
you're always been so supportive I
appreciate that man